the very language of our visual
perception and all of our senses is the
wrong language to describe objective
reality you couldn't possibly frame a
true description of objective reality in
those terms talking today with Professor
Don Hoffman who's an American cognitive
psychologist and a popular science
author he is a professor up the road at
the University of California Irvine he
has joint appointments in the department
of philosophy the department of logic
and philosophy of science in the school
of computer science he's written many
books today we're going to be talking
about a very provocative book called the
case against reality and you can find
some more information about him uh and
his Ted Talk is really where I got
introduced to him called do we see
reality as it is you can find that
wherever TED Talks are sold Don it's
such a great pleasure to uh to meet you
videog graphically and elsewise uh how
are you doing today well thank you so
much Brian it's a great pleasure I'm
doing very very well and it's a great
pleasure to talk with you thanks for
this kind invitation ah the pleasure is
truly all mine and followed to you we
have many friends in common we have many
interest in common and the first thing I
love to do because uh it's it's a nice
way to kind of open up the conversation
is by doing what we're always advised
never to do which is to judge a book by
its cover and I want to ask you how you
came up with this very delightful
delicious uh delirium inducing cover uh
image for the case against reality so if
you're at home folks go to Amazon.com
buy a copy of the book I can't recommend
it highly enough I just gave it a festar
review it's got 534 fstar reviews and up
anyway Don how'd you come up with the
the cover image and the title and
subtitle because it's very provocative
that is actually the the brainchild of a
guy named Petri and uh Bradley dumai so
this is a well-known subjective NEC Cube
that's been around for for since the
1976 1977 seven and so it was just
adapted a little bit for the cover so so
Petri and Bradley deserve all the all
the credit for that and the title yeah
it's a bit provocative I do believe that
there might be some kind of reality but
the point is that what we take to be
reality isn't the reality and that's
that's what the book is is after whether
there's a real reality beyond what we
believe is an interesting and open
question but um at least the SpaceTime
reality SpaceTime and physical objects
uh that's where I think Evolution might
say that we need to rethink
things and the subtitle is equally
provocative in my opinion the subtitle
for those who aren't uh haven't yet
received the delivery in their Amazon
realtime delivery system which I'm sure
will be coming any day now is the the
subtitle is why Evolution hid the truth
from our eyes now Don I'm not that great
a scientist but I was always told that
science that that science can't answer
why questions why did you use the word
why but I always that science answers
how questions first of all where am I
wrong I'm sure I am so this has to do
with the logic of evolution and
evolutionary Game Theory so in
evolutionary Game Theory we we can
actually ask the question technically
would natural selection shape sensory
systems of organ organisms like humans
but but of any creatures would would
their sensory systems be shaped to tell
them truths about objective reality
whatever objective reality might be and
that's that's a question that we can ask
uh very precisely using evolutionary
Game Theory and the reason I can say why
is because I can say why the logic of
evolution itself entails the probability
of zero that our sensory systems are
shaped to see any structure of objective
reality so whatever ever objective
reality might be whatever structures it
might
have um one can prove and this is work
that's been done in collaboration with
some of my graduate students and then a
a mathematician so The Graduate students
are Justin Mark and Brian Maran and and
and the mathematician uh chayon pros and
others that have worked with us on on
this and what what the simulations
Illustrated and what the mathematics
proves is that the probability is
precisely zero that any structure of
objective real
would
be preserved in the sensory systems of
any organisms by natural selection so
we're going to be selected to see
something or to perceive something the
question is the structure of our
perceptions will they somehow capture
true structures in objective reality and
the answer is no almost surely and so
that's why Evolution shapes us not to
see reality um because the probability
is zero um that it could
and and we can go into why but the the
real the the the interesting reason to
me is that you can think about evolution
is like a game like a video game right
and and when you're playing the game
what you have to do is grab points as
quickly as you can if you get enough
points in a short enough amount of time
then you can go on to the next level
well in in everyday life with natural
selection it's like a game the The
Fitness payoffs are the the thing that
sort of counts like the the points of
the game and if you get enough Fitness
payoffs um you don't go to the next
level of the game but your Offspring
your genes go to the next level of the
game and and so so it turns out that the
payoffs when when you look at the
structure of these payoff functions and
evolution the payoff functions that are
again like the the rewards that you get
in a video game how many points you get
for killing that that alien or or you
know driving that car that fast and so
forth all the points that you get those
payoff functions in evolutionary theory
do depend on the state of the world and
the structure of the world but they also
depend on the organism like a human
versus a cow versus a lion uh it State
hungry versus sad and the action feeding
fighting fleeing and mating the the big
um activities of life and so it depends
on all these things including the
structure and state of the world however
when you what we did was a combinatorial
study we can ask how many we can look at
all the possible payoff functions we can
count them and then we can ask how many
of those payoff functions would actually
preserve a particular structure in the
world say a topology we we didn't do
topology but we did measurable
structures certain kinds of uh groups uh
and and also total orders and what we
find in each case is that the
probability is precisely zero uh a 0%
fraction of the um total payoff
functions would preserve the structure
of the world so so the bottom line is
the reason why evolution by natural
selection does not shape us to see truth
is because the payoff functions that
guide Evolution don't contain the truth
almost surely that's why and when we
think about Truth uh of course you know
the common parland truth is subjective
there are alternative facts there's fake
news um so there there is sort of a
theme running through the book of you
know reality kind of being created as
you say you know almost virtual reality
without the virtual in other words we we
sort of have this headset that we're uh
encased in and it's the overlay of
perception I want to start uh by going
back to the beginning of all this at
least in terms of both not only the
scientific method but deep influence on
me and on you I know for sure and that's
this finger puppet for those of you on
clubhouse cannot see this is the finger
puppet of Galileo galile that I whip out
on occasion uh he's called the father of
modern science certainly the father of
modern astronomy and folks like Edward
tufty and others have said that he was
the first data scientist in that through
his evocative sketches and drawings of
the Moon he not only conveyed data he
conveyed emotion and senses and really
this this connection between the retina
and the objects that he was depicting
and it was sort of news to me until I
read your book I'd heard this book by
this guy Goff that we'll get into in a
little bit but how Galileo influenced
some of the modern thinking about
reality first can you say something
about Galileo and how did he contribute
to our sensation of reality and as
perceived by sensorial emot uh sensorial
senses for lack of a better word so
Galileo actually made a very interesting
distinction um between what later became
called primary and secondary qualities
um primary qualities would be things
that we think are part of objective
reality like um maybe the shape of
physical objects the positions of
physical objects in space and time and
then so those would be primary and in
some sense those would be real um and
then there were things um that or were
called secondary qualities that that
Galileo he didn't use that term but but
he was pointing in this direction Lo um
used that term or where it's been used
of Lo and his his writings on this so
things like taste and color in some
sense you know a physicist might say
look uh an object really does have a
shape and a position but it doesn't have
a real color in fact light doesn't have
color it only has say wavelengths and so
in that sense when you see color color
is something that that you make up it's
not really part of the reality the
reality in that case would just be the
wavelength of the light and so Galileo
made made that that interesting
distinction that he he said some of the
things that we perceive are not the
reality you know the real reality
they're they're just our contribution
but but I think that Galileo thought
that other things like the positions and
movements of objects their masses and so
forth would be part of the objective
reality um what was later called primary
qualities and and the other thing that I
think many scientists would credit
Galileo with was he understood about the
importance of making very careful
experimental measurements even about
boring things I mean he was rolling
balls down inclined planes and measuring
how fast they moved you might go I mean
if you're trying to understand the big
question of the universe why are you
rolling balls down in cling planes and
measuring how fast they move how how far
removed from the interesting stuff is
that but but what Galileo showed was by
doing these very careful experiments
with great precision and then trying to
model mathematically what you've what
you've seen you start to make serious
progress on the little things that
eventually are the road to the bigger
questions that you're interested in
maybe we don't care about balls on
inclined planes but then we start
learning about the deep deep laws of
nature and then they they start to open
us up to new ways of thinking about
what's going on and that's the the big
payoff right and of course you know I've
talked about this in my book losing the
Nobel Prize that that Galo is deeply
influenced by the senses and in fact in
one of the passages that that tuy I
think I'm pronouncing I never know how
to pronounce his name is that right John
Don Tu there's a famous physicist ET H
uh who won the Nobel Prize I'm trying to
get him on the end of The Impossible
podcast we'll see if that'll work out
but certainly to get to on would be to
would be great as well but he calls it
uh you know In this passage where he
calls him the first data scientist he
uses this passage about the pleades
which are also known as the Seven
Sisters OR Subaru if you happen to speak
Japanese uh and this is a small asterism
that we can see tonight from anywhere in
North America uh uh that is in the
shoulder of Taurus the Bull and these
are uh really these beautiful uh set of
stars that are young and hot and they're
surrounded as as hot young Hollywood
stars often are by an Entourage and this
entourage is in the form of a nebulosity
glow and Galileo said uh by observing
the nebulosity he thought that those
were merely uh unresolved stars that his
telescope is incapable of resolving
right and if he could resolve it it
proved that by what he calls visible
certainty we have destroyed the
arguments that have for so long vexed
philosophers of previous generations so
first of all I love that he's a
physicist of course he has to uh he has
to like poke fun at philosophers uh but
but secondly that that something can be
proven visually is a very perilous uh
proposition in my opinion to what extent
can we use perception uh as a motivation
for achieving scientific proof or
consensus whatsoever is it not a Fool's
errand The evolutionary argument that I
just gave says that the very language of
our visual perception and all of our
senses is the wrong language to describe
objective reality if that's of course
taking evolution by natural selection as
our starting point um that's just a
theorem of that of that theory we can of
course argue about evolution by natural
selection and whether we should think
that there's a deeper Theory but but
granting evolution by natural selection
as our starting point then what that
theory entails is it's not simply that
we maybe get the shape a little bit off
or the distances a little bit wrong it's
it's rather something much deeper and
that is
that Evolution natural selection entails
that the very language of space and time
and position and momentum and and
frequency and so forth is simply the
wrong language to describe objective
reality you couldn't Pro possibly frame
a true description of objective reality
in those terms now now but to your
question the that is the only language
in which we can actually make
experimental observations that's that's
what we're equipped with and so what we
have to do is go ahead and do
experiments and get data in the only
language that we can understand but then
we simply instead of assuming that that
data and the way that we normally would
think about that data is just the truth
we have to be a little bit more clever
we have to be like a person who's
wearing a a VR headset who's been
playing a video game and they can they
can sort of you know see like say it's
Grand Theft Auto with a VR souped up
version of it right and and and and you
could start to ask questions like is is
the geometry of this game a ukian
geometry and you could start to do work
with some other friends who are you know
playing the game with you and do some
experiments and and discover oh well
this is roughly a ukian geometry and and
and and do things like that and that
would be perfectly fine because that's
the only data that you can get is within
the language of the game but if you
think that that's going to take you to
uh an understanding of the deepest
reality which in this metaphor would be
the circuits and software and voltages
and magnetic fields of some hidden
supercomputer that's running the game
well you're going to be sadly mistaken
and and and wrong by thinking that you
know the ukian geometry that you
measured in the game is going to tell
you something directly about the
supercomputer that that that's running
the game you have to think outside of
the headset and so that's what evolution
by natural selection is sort of telling
us is that yeah we can only get data in
the headset um but how we interpret the
data is going to require us to think
outside of the confines of our headset
outside of in fact space and time
itself yeah and of course you know no
one really made the same impact kind of
relatively speaking as Galileo did on
the on its predecessors before we move
off of H and onto other you know
slightly more modern than the uh 16th
and the 17th century conceptions of of
sensorial perception I want to just
remind people listening on a clubhouse
that we're enjoying a conversation with
renowned professor and thinker
philosopher scholar uh Professor Don
Hoffman who I'm pleased to call a
colleague in this great wonderful
University that we call the University
of California though we may be on
separate campuses we are colleagues in
the world's greatest University uh so
don it's such a pleasure to be
affiliated with you I want to turn just
to the last statement about Galileo of
course he was involved in this
conception and many of his books
actually this is a news break for my
friends listening on clubhouse uh my uh
subscribers on YouTube know this already
but uh for many years Galileo's books
were not available uh even though they
were translated by our colleague or our
co- University inhabitant Stillman Drake
uh who was up at UC Berkeley for many
years and these translations done by him
are the definitive ones of all time
including the dialogue on Two Chief
World Systems which uh I always keep
nearby me and uh and I started to uh to
investigate this book and realized what
an amazing writer Galileo is and how
beautiful and lyrical he does write and
I said well this is great but you know
this book is 539 pages long I wish I
wish I could do what I did with Don
Hoffman's book and listen to an
audiobook version of it wouldn't that be
cool turns out the audiobook version has
never been made and I I thought to
myself well somebody's got to do this
for the Maestro and and why not let it
be me and so I poked around and I and I
found out who has permission to do this
and it was the University of California
press owns the rights to this
translation so then I thought well what
can I do with it and uh to make it kind
of theatrical and I said why don't I get
my friend Carlo relli a previous guest
on the into the podcast and he's gonna
narrate it along with me and my
colleague Lucho pillo and maybe someone
like Elena aiel or Andrea gz we got to
get some some women in there as well
because of these Italian women
especially Alita aiel if you've ever met
her a fabul anati is a hero of mine I
would just love to have an Italian woman
narrate one of the three characters
anyway it's a short yeah so I'll keep
you posted on that that's labor of love
maybe not remun in the way that I would
prefer it but anyway it's not all about
money um but I do want to say what
Galileo said is he um he talks about a
Wine's good taste does not belong to the
objective determination of the wine and
hence of an object even the object as it
appearance but the special character is
the sense in the subject who is enjoying
its taste this is an that owes to the
Nam sake of the UN I don't I don't think
it's the namesake of UC Berkeley uh but
George Berkeley tell me a little bit
about George Berkeley did he not come up
with these ideas that you know the moon
does not exist except when you're
looking at it except if you have sort of
this God's ey perspective talk about
Berkeley is he is he irrelevant or is he
more relevant than ever Berkeley had
this very interesting view uh that
everything that we perceive is in some
sense just creation of our senses and
that only he had a theological view he
he ended up being a bishop in in the
church but he had this view that even if
I'm not looking at a tree it the tree
exists only because it's in God's view
so God keeps things existing by being by
perceiving them but he said you know to
be is to be perceived uh or or to be a
perceiver so that's a very very
different point of view than physicalist
view that says uh to to be is to be for
example um something in space and time
with energy and matter um so that you
know space time energy and matter are
the fundamental Natures of objective
reality and and Barkley was saying no
the fundamental nature of existence is
being perceived or being a perceiv which
which is a very different point of view
and it was you know I think Barkley was
partly reacting against what he thought
were were the um the advances of a of a
physicalist um you know science that was
mostly materialist and and didn't leave
room perhaps for um other uh more
spiritual ideas when I look at uh these
these kind of initial thoughts initial
foray in that time of course what
Galileo was railing against back in the
dialogue uh was the notion that the
Earth was stationary and uh he said
don't you know your your senses tell
that that it's stationary and it seemed
like he's sort of arguing against
himself because in some sense they'll
say the senses can teach you everything
and and you can have visible certainty
in other words you could prove something
quades demonstrat based on visual accuse
and and Visual Evidence on the other
hand he could say like don't trust your
sensory emotion perception and I I think
it's so interesting that you connect and
you mentioned this early on the book you
talk about the grand questions and I
think of them as sort of um chicken or
egg problems in other words how did the
universe come from non- Universe how did
matter come from energy how did life
come from matter uh and all of which you
know Darwin you know sort of presupposed
was was a crazy thing to ever think
about now we know it as big bang
nucleosynthesis and then lastly how does
Consciousness emerge from you know
bacteria how did how do he go from
bacteria to Bach or um you know anything
like that and you talk about the survey
in Science magazine arguably the number
one or two journal in the world 2006
asked what are the big questions for The
Next Century the number one of course I
Pat myself on the back hurting my
shoulder uh was uh what of what is the
universe made and then number two was
how does biology produce Consciousness
in my yeah in my expertise at least in
thinking about this I don't know if
we'll ever have an answer uh you know of
what the universe has made or what
predated our universe these are active
subjects of of um of debate and
scientific inquiry is it true in biology
that this is still considered a
plausible possible outcome that biology
could predict how Consciousness
emerges I would say among my peers in
cognitive Neuroscience the those who of
my colleagues they're brilliant
colleagues of mine who are working on
this I would say that 95 99% of them uh
take it for granted that um in human
beings and other animals conscious
experiences are a product of brain
activity um and we just have to figure
out what kind of brain activity causes
which kinds of brain experiences and
what kinds of conscious experiences and
how that happens I mean there are
theories for example that say Roger
Penrose for example and Stuart hamov uh
together have a theory that says that
certain structures called microtubules
and neurons have certain electrons with
special Quantum States and if you can
get an orchestrated collapse of these
Quantum States using some of penrose's
ideas about gravitational collapses of
of quantum States you get the right
orchestrated collapse of these Quantum
States then that will cause conscious
experiences that's what Consciousness is
others say that no it's more like the
architecture of how information is
passed through the nervous system
through through the brain um certain
information that's broadcast widely is
going to be conscious information that
sort of stuck in certain parts of the
architecture and isn't widely available
throughout the entire system will not be
conscious but if it's broadcast widely
it will be so this is the so-called
Global neuronal workspace Theory Bernard
bars and other are involved in in this
and then there's one that says um well
it's more like sort of causal
computational architectures that nervous
systems or or other physical systems
might have this is integrated
information Theory it says if you have
the right causal computational
architecture then and it has something
called High integration of information
they call it fee High integrated
information but called fee then that
will lead to or or be conscious
experience and so so the idea is a a
reductionist idea you start with space
time and matter and physical objects and
then you have to show from those
foundations how Consciousness emerges
and and that's part of a bigger picture
of which you're far better aware than me
which is the Big Bang cosmology and the
idea is that you at the Big Bang there
was only space time and energy and
matter there was no life so that took
hundreds of millions maybe billions of
years before life came around and then
who knows how much longer after that
before Consciousness came around so
surely it must be that Consciousness
emerges from SpaceTime and matter uh so
that's why most of my colleagues are
reductionist in this
way the payoff or or perhaps the
adjacency of the problem
often comes up in what I do which is
sometimes works to our detriment and
I'll say you know we do get this sort of
fear or concern for lack of a better
word that you have uh you know being too
close to the woow woo side of things and
and science is never a good a good thing
and in fact you know I was going to play
a game with you but I don't have time to
do it which would be you know what I
call high and low where we take the
highest verified review on Amazon of
this book and the lowest verified review
on uh Amazon and we compare them and uh
but I I'll spare you it but the but the
problem is the the lowest I mean it's
got 500 F star reviews the only you know
one star review that I can find that
really you know is kind of criticizing
it says well oh really you have deepo
Chopra I guess on the printed book I
listen to the audiobook version but the
printed book has you deep choer
endorsement I know you guys have worked
together he's been a guest on my show
two or three times uh already and uh
he's also contributed to the endorsement
encomia on a book uh by Frank wilchek
who you may know won the Nobel Prize in
2014 and these are and he's commented on
his book so uh so the the criticism is
oh how could you have Deepu choer I I
don't know if the guy even read it um
but but the bottom line is is is it
sometimes the case that these that these
books run the danger of being too close
to maybe science fiction or this notion
of the mind of God and we can understand
the mind of God I've seen this a lot
with even in this book you know to give
the uh the devil is due uh whoever wrote
that one star
review plethora of references to the
Matrix I see that in many books
including Galileo's error this book by
goof that we might get a chance to talk
about um so what do you think about this
and the notion that comes usually
concomitantly with it of pans psychism
which is maybe you could describe what
is pans psychism is it woo is it woo woo
adjacent what do you think right well
this is a very important question and
the the one thing I would say is that
you know as scientists uh we get our
ideas in many many different places
casual conversations a glass of beer
reading a paper it's it's all over the
place but what we do as scientists is we
then take them and we have to be very
precise in writing them down as
mathematical uh precise theories and
then we go test them so so my attitude
is I mean I I talk with people from from
all sorts of areas and all sorts of
religious and scientific fields and I
get ideas wherever I I can and of course
I'm I'm critical of the ideas I'm
critical of my own ideas you know that's
just the way science works so get your
ideas wherever you want to what makes
science different is that no matter
where you get the ideas now you've got
to make them mathematically precise
you've got to make testable predictions
and then you've got to go out and test
them so that's where you get away from
the woo doesn't matter where you get the
ideas the question is what do you do
with them and how rigorously do you
frame them and test them once you've
gotten them and so that's that's the key
the key point for me now in Pan psychism
the reason why pan psychism and several
other ideas have been starting to catch
favor among cognitive neuroscientists
and philosophers studying Consciousness
is that uh the physicalist
approach uh even though it seems to be
well motivated by you the standard
reductionist framework in which
SpaceTime is fundamental started at the
big bang and so forth it it seems to
have all the right pedigree and the
right framework we've not been able to
solve a single specific conscious
experience all the theories I gave you
orchestrated collapse of microtubules
integrated information Theory Global
workspace if you ask these brilliant
researchers some of them are good
friends of mine just ask them as I do
sometimes on stage at conferences great
great Theory so what what specific
experience can you tell me what's the
integrated information for the taste of
vanilla or the smell of chocolate or or
whatever you want and they can't give
one so the the weird thing about it is
that no physicalist Theory Of
Consciousness to date can explain even
one specific conscious experience and
say this is the particular causal
computational architecture the right
integrated information that must be the
taste of vanilla it could not be the the
taste of chocolate and these are the
exact reasons why and if you made this
particular change to the causal
architecture it wouldn't necessarily
change it into the smell of a rose there
there's just nothing like that on the
table and and and the hard thing is that
that it's not like we go oh well but we
can see how we could do it we actually
don't see how we could make that
connection what how are you going to go
from a causal computational architecture
or a global you know broadcasting to
that must be the the smell of of AR rows
how do you do that without a big leap
and so that's been a a big big problem
so this has then that was one thing that
led me to begin to question the whole
reductionist framework and to ask
Evolution I mean is that a you know
maybe space time and and matter and
objects aren't the fundamental nature of
reality and an evolution come back comes
back and says they aren't that's the
wrong language but in pan psychism now
what we have is a move to try to come at
things at a different tack the idea is
if
you can't boot up Consciousness from
space time and
matter maybe you can somehow get
Consciousness coming in as a primary
concept
now it there's two ways that this is
done what one is a monist way in which
you say okay let's just start with
Consciousness as the only thing that
there is so we have a mathematical model
of Consciousness on its own terms and we
have to then show how space time and
matter emerge or you can have a more of
a of a dualist kind of version where you
say let's let's say that there's um
physical stuff and and its structure and
also Consciousness and have them somehow
interact uh the way pan work is they
there are many versions of it so I'll
pick the one that I think is the most
common version it it says look um
physics gives us these equations for how
matter operates and how the world works
but it doesn't tell us what's inside the
equations it's just it's just how things
operate but it doesn't tell us what the
intrinsic nature of those things is so
maybe when we talk about the wave
equation of an electron maybe that you
know that equation is just how something
behaves but it's not telling us what it
is that behaves what is an electron
really or what's inside the electron and
so panica says well maybe there's some
Consciousness there maybe what's really
going on inside electron is that there's
some Consciousness and so so the idea is
that certain particles or certain
combinations of particles like maybe uh
a a neutron which has you know three
quirks in it that that might be
conscious as well so quarks are
conscious or have Consciousness three
quarks together can make a proton or
neut neon and and those are conscious
but some combinations like the things
that go into making a rock maybe that's
the wrong kind of combination and so a
rock isn't conscious and so so the idea
there is to you it can be run in a
dualist version sometimes they call it a
neutral monist version it's it's a
little slippery I I tend to think of it
somewhat as as dualist but I think
others who are panus might disagree but
the key point is that there's you take
the laws of physics and where you find
an entity like an or a proton or
something like that you can put
Consciousness as the intrinsic thing
that's actually being governed by those
equations um now I myself am not a pan
psychist I I don't think that that
Approach at least the one I just
described is is radical enough I I think
that there are good reasons on physics
grounds to think that SpaceTime itself
is doomed that space time is not
fundamental that that physics even if
they are not interested in Consciousness
per se um that physics itself has to
look for something deeper than SpaceTime
and this is work by Nar arani Hamed and
other physicists who who will give
arguments from you know gravity and this
interaction with quantum theory that
that say that you know you you there are
no local observables in SpaceTime um
there's just no it cannot be fundamental
and they're looking for deeper
structures they're finding things like
amplitud hedrin associahedron
cosmological polytopes that are deeper
structures that that have no Hilbert
spaces so there's no quantum theory they
have no locality uh no Loren and
variance themselves so they don't care
about locality and SpaceTime but they
nevertheless they have deep structures
that can give rise to for example
scattering amplitudes they can predict
scattering amplitudes and they can they
can be projected into SpaceTime and show
you how you get locality and unitarity
so so so the the panus views I think are
are too Limited they they typically take
the current space-time laws of physics
as foundational and are trying to stick
Consciousness into the interest tises
there and I think the physicists
themselves are telling us when they're
going for things like the amplitud
hedrin look there's a whole new level of
of logic and and structure that we need
to look for outside of SpaceTime yeah I
should say of course to listeners so
we're talking with Professor Donald
Hoffman renowned philosopher cognitive
scientist and deep thinker author of the
current book we're talking about today
is the case against reality uh which
makes astonishing claims not unrelated
to the astonishing hypothesis of Francis
Crick to which we will soon turn uh I do
want to see if there are any questions
uh first in clubhouse I see there's at
least one hand that is raised and maybe
two so let's get them up on stage Cammy
if you could get them up there so don
we're going to put the phone up to uh to
the microphone and uh we'll take a
question first from Haren Heron do you
have a question for Dr
Hoffman well it wasn't actually a
question it was just a quick observation
if that's acceptable sure if it's quick
yeah uh as I see it I only have
available to me my immediate sensory
experience and stories about my
immediate sensory experience the very
idea of reality is a linguistic
construction is a story an attempt to
make sense of my sensory experience
which is completely mysterious all the
theories that talk about perception and
that you're being something outside
responsible for constructing my
perception those are stories and they
may be interesting stories and even
useful stories but they're no more than
stories reality is a story I'll leave it
at that any reaction
Don yes uh none of us knows for sure
what objective reality might might be
and and there is some there are some
philosophers like Emanuel Kant who said
look there's the Numa and the phenomena
the phenomena what we can experience
what we can measure what we can do
empirical science with and the Numa he
Kant at least in some interpretations of
Kant said um it that's the objective
reality but there's nothing that really
we can say about it it's beyond um the
realm of what we can do you know science
about and of course for for scientists
you know I want to try to give a theory
of objective reality I want that's what
we do we we tend to be uh realist about
our theories in the sense that we're
we're proposing things that we think
might be true descriptions of of
objective reality um Kant might be right
there may the Numa the the reality um
may be beyond anything that humans can
ever approach and there's a a book by
Yan westerhoff um which uh where he
makes an argument there there is no
objective reality in the framework of EV
evolution by natural
selection that theory does posit an
objective reality as part of the
framework of the theory and payoff
functions are mappings from that
objective reality into payoff values and
so in that framework what I can say is
if there is some kind of objective
reality and it has some structure then
evolution by natural selection that
theory entails the probability of zero
that we see any of that structure now
that doesn't entail though that we don't
have the conceptual systems to try think
outside of our sensory headset right the
the virtual reality that Evolution gave
us we may have the conceptual capacity
to think outside of the box of our
senses and try to get understandings of
the structure of objective reality just
like for example I can't imagine a
specific color I've never seen before
right if you say if I ask you think of a
specific color imagine a concrete color
that you've never seen before well I
mean nothing happens I smoke comes out
of my ears nothing happens and and yet I
do have the conceptual capacity to
imagine that there could be colors that
I could never see and to imagine for
example if I'm my male dichromat that
maybe these people that that are trir
chromates maybe they really are seeing
colors that I could never even
concretely imagine and so so it's it's
certainly seems legitimate to say that
even though my sensory system can't
reveal this thing to me directly my
cognitive systems can help me go where
my senses might fail and so I think a
lot of scientists
take that attitude about this thing but
but my answer in bottom line is who
knows what reality is right even if our
theories work and pass every test it
doesn't mean they're right so we can
never know for sure if we've got it
that's right and I want to turn to that
next uh especially this notion of ITP
which uh is in stands for interface
theory of perception which uh which is
something that that you coined and I
want to understand how we can we can
think of it when you say interface you
literally mean a type of interface and
and the question is in in what way is it
a description of reality is what way is
it an analogy which I'm not even denying
the validity or necessity of an analogy
in this case but to what extent is it
real I mean we'll get to Nema and stuff
later who hopefully will be coming on
the podcast shortly um but the the
question of of you know is it an analogy
which has utility to help us visualize
things or is it itself this infinite
Turtles all the way down and and you're
just like substituting one uh
description of something uh
undescribable for another well I would
say first if I just think in terms of
the framework of evolution by natural
selection just The Logical framework of
that theory what that theory entails is
that there it assumes that there's an
objective reality it assumes that there
are organisms that are being shaped with
sensory systems and the theory then says
that it's a theorum of that theory that
the sensory systems will not ever
reveal true structures of that objective
reality instead they will give you
sensory systems that serve only as
guides to Adaptive Behavior so you're
not the the whole point is not to see
the truth the whole point is to stay
alive long enough to reproduce that's
that's so that's the structure of
evolutionary theory so so once you
understand that sensory systems are not
Windows on the truth they're merely
guides to Adaptive Behavior
then then I say well you know people
then ask well how how could that
possibly be you know help me understand
and I think that's when the metaphor of
a virtual reality headset or a user
interface on your laptop those are the
kinds of metaphors I think help us to
understand what the mathematics of
evolution is is is telling us like when
you use your laptop you're writing a
paper or a book or something like that
and the icon for the book on your
desktop is blue and rectangular in the
middle of your screen it doesn't mean
that the book in the computer is blue
and rectangular in the middle of your
computer somehow I mean there's no
mapping like that between your senses
and the objective reality instead what
you see on your laptop hides the truth
and that's why it's valuable you don't
want to see the voltages and magnetic
fields and the circuits and software I
mean if you had to toggle voltages to
write your book good luck you you'd
never finish your book and and so that's
what evolution did it it gives us a user
interface now now that part is now I'm
just using a metaphor mean for what what
evolution has given us but it's given us
a user interface that hides the truth
but lets us control the truth whatever
that truth might be in a simple way
using simple user interface uh icons you
know when I think about that um that
that fruitful metaphor that you're using
I I can't help but escape the fact that
we are talking on clubhouse
simultaneously uh friends are tweeting
out it will be recorded on uh on YouTube
it will have a uh it will have a a
lifelong presence perhaps uh forever but
you know there's a distinction I hope to
get you on uh on on clubhouse by the end
of this conversation or teach you how to
get on as I have so many people before
because so many people did it for me but
what's nice about Clubhouse is it's
purely audio so you just drop in listen
I'm gonna take more questions uh we're
speaking with Professor Don Hoffman you
Irvine friend and colleague and uh and
and really a Titan of this field with
novel Innovative and testable ideas and
that's what I think is so draws me to
what you do and and we might disagree
about you know certain aspects of it of
course you are uh far more eminent in
this domain but what's interesting about
Clubhouse is that it's a very low
bandwidth thing I mean only I can talk
or only you can talk or only one of my
the people that are up on stage or soon
will be can talk so it's it's a single
channel so to speak whereas Twitter we
can read really fast we can perceive
information really fast read hundreds of
words per minute I always say like some
of the people probably some people that
are listening to us right now wish there
was a 2X speed uh for Clubhouse the way
there is for uh listening to podcast uh
but you and I speak pretty quickly so I
I think I think I think we're doing okay
but um but the bottom line is Clubhouse
acts as a filter in a certain sense and
it is almost as important what
information we choose to discard as the
information that we choose to get past
the filter and so you're arguing that
ution is designed adaptive filters we
call them P proportional interir
derivative feedback circuits Etc but
there's always a liness to any
filtration system and I wonder in The
evolutionary
framework um you know there are some
things that it's clear that we derive
pleasure from them but it's not clear
that it's a fitness boosting as a metric
uh for example music when I'm listening
to music I'm perceiving there's tons of
things that are going on or or and I
smell a smell that might be
easy to see what the purpose May reminds
me it's danger toest that but there's
where it doesn't seem there's a fitness
payf in the human I agree in birds and
whales probably I don't know I'm not a
biologist uh but but the point is what
is the purpose evolutionarily speaking
of this most August you know kind of uh
uh trait of the human species to make
music for no purpose whatsoever it
seemed biologically wasteful at least
from a novice perspective like mine
evolutionary psychologists have thought
a lot about this uh Steven Pinker has
has got some good ideas he calls music
um auditory cheesecake it's you know
something that uh cheesecake sort of
hits our senses in a very very strong
way all the positive things right we in
some sense in the case of taste we you
know fatty foods are really good for us
they have high calories sugary foods are
are really good for us they we need the
energy and so forth and in during the
Pline it was hard for us to get these
things and so if we find a food like
cheesecake that has all of them um You'
never find perhaps cheesecake during the
plene but now that we can make it it
hits all the things that were shaped by
Evolution during the pine and so so we
go for it in the case of auditory stuff
we do use auditory information to tell
us um for example who's attractive some
people's voices um are more attractive
than others and that will have some
correlation with the reproductive
Fitness of that person um you know the
the voice of a 99 year-old um has
certain qualities to it that are
different from the voice of a 21y old
and we pick up on those qualities and we
can infer something about the age of the
person and that in terms of reproductive
potential then leads to certain
attraction or or not and so those kinds
of arguments can can be given for why we
find certain pattern patterns of
auditory um stimulation more attractive
than others because they in the past and
in the present are are correlated with
um with reproductive potential and and
and fitness enhancement so in music now
what what happens is just like with with
you know cheesecake you start to someone
figures out to how to put all these
wonderful ingredients together and you
get something that you would never
perhaps ever heard in nature uh but now
it's like cheesecake which would never
exist in nature until we put all these
ingredients together so that may be one
aspect of it but there may be more also
to music in the sense of a social joint
cooperative and bonding experience that
comes from music you so so again you
know tribes in our evolutionary past
often when they went out to hunt or
fight would have some kind of um
chanting or music together so it can be
a bonding thing so so I would say that
from an evolutionary point of view from
evolutionary psychology the kind of
question question that you you asked
Brian is is a non-trivial one but we we
have ideas about how to try to come to
rigorous
answers yeah um so now I want to take
another question from the audience I
have a friend of mine Mark LoveIt who is
a uh a very deep thinker he is up in the
in the stage in clubhouse Mark do you
have a a comment or question for Dr
Hoffman you know how are humans supposed
to interact with you know the real quote
unquote world if our memory is so flawed
and our ability to comprehend reality
just doesn't work so well that would be
my question great great question and and
and I would say um my my own attitude is
is I certainly agree that we don't see
reality as it is that our beliefs are
not necessarily the truth and I take
that as a welcome wakeup I I don't find
it discouraging at all it's it's a
wonderful realization it's like like
someone that's had a VR headset on all
their life and they thought that the
virtual world that they were in was the
fundamental reality and you finally tell
them you know what everything that
you've seen is just a virtual reality
headset and I'm I'm about to take the
headset off well that's that's good news
so science has the
tools to try to go beyond just what our
senses tell us um and and so I think
that you know we can never know if we've
succeeded
but we don't have to give up so I think
this is a fabulous time actually in the
Sciences science I would say from this
point of view from an evolutionary point
of view for the since Galileo we've been
sharpening our tools by understanding
our headset so we've really learned how
to use experimental and mathematical
tools we've studied our headset we we
really have done it so well that our
theories are now so good evolution of
natural selection Quantum field Theory
and gravity are so good that they tell
us SpaceTime is not fundamental they're
telling us you've been studying the
headset that's an incredible Vindication
of science it's telling us that even
though you assume that you were looking
at the truth uh you're not you just
looking at a headset but now use those
same tools to try to come up with
theories beyond space and time and the
way that you test those ideas
is to take make them mathematically
precise so like what Nema is doing with
the with his structures outside of
SpaceTime like the amplitud hedrin or
something like that make them
mathematically rigorous show exactly how
they project into SpaceTime and see the
predictions that they make there and if
you can then you can test them you can
you only see things in your headset so
that's where the experiments have to be
done in your headset but you can still
test models outside the headset as long
as you have a mathematical model about
how they project into the headset so
that's what science is now going to be
up to we're taking our first foray out
of our headset out of space and time and
science is up to the task so this is a
for me an exciting opportunity and and
not a time to be um discouraged Don do
you know that Galileo actually invented
an actual VR or ar headset which was a
type of chronograph that was based on a
telescope the telescope looking at the
moons of Jupiter so you'd wear this
helmet and you'd look at the moons of
Jupiter and would have a telescope built
into it and you'd augment your reality
your vision in this case and you'd be
able to see the moons and this is a huge
problem back in the 1600s to tell time
and in fact he was impelled by the
desire that impels many of us professors
to make money and to capitalize on no
I'm just kidding uh we're not all Don I
shouldn't I shouldn't accuse him of my
own venal motivations but but Galileo
had this uh VR headset that he put on
that had a telescope and uh he didn't
win win the longitude prize but uh but
eventually uh it was it was it was and
is used to do many other some say more
important things like test and measure
the speed of light and its constancy
throughout our solar system uh I didn't
know that that's wonderful Yeah question
from H Max AB bitball who's a colleague
of mine Dr Max would you like to ask Dr
Hoffman a question the question was is
consciousness a
unique filter into real or is it just
our
filter well so the answer is I don't
know but I can just tell you how I'm
thinking about this um in cognitive
Neuroscience we have this problem of
Consciousness we call it the hard
problem of Consciousness which is how
our our experience of you know Taste of
chocolate smell of garlic sound of a
trumpet how is are these conscious
experiences related to neural activity
in the brain or perhaps to circuits and
software in an AI system and we've come
up empty trying to start with the
physical systems and boot up
Consciousness we've just come up empty
we can't I mean I'm not saying we can't
do it but we we've had very very bright
people including Nobel Prize winners
many of them working on this and we've
come up empty so far and and it it seems
to me to be principled that we can't
start with space time and matter and
boot up Consciousness and so there's two
responses one is to say well there's no
such thing as Consciousness It's Just an
Illusion so Dan dennet and Keith
Frankish will say this and of course
then they have to explain how the
illusion of Consciousness arises right
so how do I what is the brain activity
that causes the illusion of the taste of
vanilla so there is no such thing as the
conscious experience of the taste of of
vanilla but nevertheless somehow our
brain has duped us into having the
illusion of the taste of vanilla so they
still owe us a mathematically precise
theory about what are the neural
processes precisely that lead to the
illusion of the taste of vanilla and why
those processes could not be the
illusion of the sound of a trumpet so
and and there's nothing there yet but
there's the other approach I'm taking um
now to get to your question I I don't
view Consciousness as a filter but I'm
saying if if I don't start with space
time and matter maybe I can start with
Consciousness not as an emergent
property of SpaceTime but as an entity
that I want to mathematically model on
its own terms so I want a simple
mathematical structure that I claim
captures everything there is to claim to
to capture fundamentally about
Consciousness and I want to look then at
the mathematical implications of that
formalism and then show that somehow
there's this dynamics of Consciousness
and that can give rise to SpaceTime so
SpaceTime is not fundamental in any
sense and and scale structure in
SpaceTime is in no way fundamental to
Consciousness that Consciousness itself
is fundamental my attitude is very much
like touring when when he was trying to
come up with a theory of computation
right computation is a wild and wooly
Enterprise there's
traveling salesman problem Computing Pi
there's NP complete problem there's tons
of stuff in computation touring managed
to find this drop dead trivial formalism
finite set of States a halt State start
State a set of transition rules and and
that turned out to be enough to you know
have the church touring thesis anything
that's computable can be computed by a
touring machine I want the same thing
for Consciousness a minimal
formalism that um has combinatorial
properties that can allow me to build a
theory of anything that I want to have
about Consciousness the self learning
memory problem solving intelligence I
want to build all those things from a a
strip down version of conscious so
that's the attitude in which I'm
thinking about it Consciousness from
this point of view isn't like just a
filter it's the whole thing um now again
I'm probably wrong but I'm just telling
you the strategy that I'm taking I don't
want to start with space time and matter
because that doesn't seem to work so let
me start with Consciousness and see if I
can boot that up so yeah I should say I
had so yeah speaking of CH uh of Turing
we had on Nome Chomsky on the into the
impossible podcast over the summer and
Nome was saying uh things you know that
you know Turing considered certain
questions such as you know can machines
think is like utterly ridiculous and
that brings up one of these Notions that
I want to talk to you about which is you
know this this notion of increasing comp
computational ability Quantum Computing
Etc whereas nema's uh theories and he
hasn't uh he has agreed to come on the
into the impossible podcast and we'll
talk to him about this uh his his
theories I would say are of course he's
he's incredibly brilliant very creative
and inventive but they're by no means
mainstream they're by no means accepted
at the same level of most of the other
physics content of this book the case
against reality so I just want to
caution people that because Nema is
conjecturing it doesn't necessarily mean
it's it's established fact or even
accepted by even a majority of
physicists even though it has it has
some promise and and I would say you
know there are alternatives Loop quantum
gravity even strength Theory Etc that
are trying to parameterize the the uh
fundamental you know dichotomy between
SpaceTime is fundamental or emergent um
primitive or or somehow Elementary
versus it not being so so the question I
have is about uh conscious computers so
uh not only let's just skip Turing and
say chomsky's wrong turing's uh you know
can computers be conscious if if if uh I
don't see why not according you know at
least if I put on my naive pan ISM hat I
don't know why not anything you know
just silicon and and or Jose's
injunctions or whatever so can they be
conscious and if they are and if we are
you know somehow a virtual Perce
perception or perceiving entities uh
then who's to say that we're not
simulated as as people have have
conjectured and and I'm sure that'll
generate some follow-up questions from
from the audience yeah so go ahead yeah
great question so there are a couple
Frameworks to try to answer that in a
physicalist framework so space time and
matter are fundamental then the attitude
is that of course machines can be
conscious the brain is a machine and
it's conscious so so we have a firsthand
example so John surl at UC Berkeley has
made that argument and I think like 99%
of my colleagues in cognitive
Neuroscience say of course right brains
are machines they're carbon based
machines not silicon based machines but
they're machines and they create
Consciousness and we just have to work
out how how it's done
and and they may be right that so in
that case yes and if that's true then I
would say absolutely if carbon based
machines can create conscious then then
certainly there's nothing against
silicon-based machines now I've argued
though that there's principal reasons
why you can't start with inanimate
matter and boot up Consciousness that I
I I think it just can't be done and that
the whole big bang cosmology has to be
rethought in in that regard and maybe
start with Consciousness being
fundamental now in the case of pans
psychism uh once again the pans psychism
has Consciousness in some sense being
fundamental it's not derived from matter
but it's sort of the heart of of matter
it's it's the to use Hawkings phrase
It's the the fire inside the equations
right that that that's that's what
Consciousness is so in that sense surely
the right kinds of machines will have
the right kinds of pans psychic
Consciousness so that's a second
framework in which you can can think
about it the wrong kind of machine is a
rock right it has the wrong kind of
architecture so the combinatorial way in
which atoms combined to make a rock is
not the right kind of combinatorics to
have the rock have its own special
consciousness of its own kind that's
above and beyond all the consciousnesses
of the particles so that's the sort of
the combination issue that comes up in
pan psychism certain combinations will
have Consciousness associated with them
others will not and so you have to be
precise about that and and panas are are
are struggling to to do that in the
framework that I'm working on
Consciousness is
fundamental um so it's not arising in
any way from physics instead physics in
SpaceTime is just the headset that
certain Consciousness is used so the the
metaphor I like to give is the Twitter
verse the vast social network of
interacting um agents in the Twitter
verse there's tens of millions of users
billions of tweets there's no way that
any Twitter user can and grapple with
the whole thing and read all the tweets
so we have visualization tools for vast
social data that's overwhelming we have
visualization tools and so in this view
in which I'm proposing that Ultimate
Reality is a vast social network of
interacting consciousnesses like the
Twitter verse so that's the fundamental
reality then SpaceTime is just one
headset one kind of data structure one
visualization tool that certain of the
agents use to help them roock or
interact with other agents now once we
under if we think about it that way I
need to write down a mathematical model
of of the Dynamics of these agents of
the headset the mapping of the Dynamics
of conscious agents into the headset
once I've done that then we can try to
reverse engineer that mapping and say
mean the headset is there to give me
contact with certain conscious agents or
to give me trends about what these
conscious agents are doing just like you
get Trends in in in Twitter so the
question would be could I once I know
how this space-time headset Works can I
open new portals in that headset to new
consciousnesses and with some of those
portals the technology needed to make
those portals look like Silicon and
circuits and my answer is probably I
mean it's probably possible once we
understand the headset we can reverse
engineer it right right now my headset
when I see your face I've got a portal
into your Consciousness fallible but
genuine portal into your Consciousness
so we know that this headset under this
framework gives us portals into
Consciousness could we have a precise
enough understanding of this headset and
of its relationship to conscious agents
that we could reverse engineer it I
think yes and I think some of the
technology may look like uh artificial
intelligence but we wouldn't be doing it
in reductionist framework we're not
starting with circuits and software that
are unconscious and booting up
Consciousness we're starting with
conscious
and a headset that's been constructed by
conscious agents we're reverse
engineering it to open up new portals to
other conscious agents so it's a
completely different framework you talk
a lot in the book about experience and
I've been thinking about a quote I heard
from Sam Harris once which was which is
something to do with um you know that
the most valuable quantity in life isn't
time you know because time we waste
everyone says you know money is so
valuable no you can make money back you
can't make time back you know if I ask
you Don you know could you would you
like to trade this last two hours of of
your generosity you probably say yeah
give me that back I'd love to have that
time back to play with my uh my friends
and do whatever I but but in reality
it's actually according to Sam Harris
it's attention right so you have a c
certain amount of attention and that's
the most conserved quantity because we
all have time to watch you know Lord
knows I've watched a lot of cat videos
but I've been thinking a lot about it
and I and I can't I can't help but ask
you in the remaining minutes before we
wrap up um and I want to ask you
something I I actually think the most
valuable precious commodity is innocence
because I have a bunch of kids and and
I'm I'm so amazed by their learning and
their growth every day and when I see
something like time or even attention uh
it's it's reversible in the sense that
like okay so you could rejuvenate if
you're really drained or or okay so you
you did all this you wasted all this
time you know eating and watching the
Super Bowl but now you can go for a run
but in a sense you really can't you
really can't get back and and I see that
and I've talked to I've talked to men
who've gone to war and and and how to
take lives of the enemy and they said
they they can never undo that and and
that was the biggest loss of their
innocence it wasn't the drugs that they
did it was and so I caution people um
and I've had addicts on the show and
I've had people uh that really opened up
in ways I never thought I was talking
about physics all of a sudden this guy
tells me that you know he's had to kill
people in his life in service of his
country and it breaks my heart because I
know he's a good soul and I'm not
condemning it at all uh and there are
listeners right now in this room who
have been to war and and then I I've
heard people that been drug addicts and
and I know that the last comment you
know is not maybe you know to do
anything really hurt yourself but is
there irreversibility I mean am I doing
some sort of child abuse to my kids and
I I actually just tell them I'm like you
do these drugs it's it's irreversible
and I'm talking about my experience my
children my experience in my life there
are things that you know we always talk
about how you know well I wouldn't have
been the person I was today if X Y and Z
didn't happen to me and actually I've
looked at this and all the guests I've
had on 116 guests now 117 with Don's
gracing us on the on the podcast uh but
uh but you know thinking about you know
kind of the experiences and yeah I
wouldn't trade anything I wouldn't you
know I I am the result of all my
experiences in a certain sense but again
I'm just asking Don you know from a from
a neurochemical perspective uh are there
way is there you know a possibility that
that certain drugs are not um are one
way ratchets and Pauls in the in the fem
manian sense that it can only go in One
Direction and for people like me perhaps
uh shouldn't shouldn't try it by the way
I might have a more addictive
personality I know I have addiction to
food and I'm Addicted to Love uh but but
the point I'm trying to make down is is
are there drug experiences that you
really can't come back from uh yes I
think that there are some of course that
are that may open your mind and be
harmless and others that could be IR
irreversible and there's going to be
individual differences so you know you
are taking a a chance just like if you
have dinner and eat mushrooms you're
taking a chance too right I mean some I
have friends that eating a mushroom is
fine for me but for them it's it's
irreversible so so there are we are
taking these chances I I think you know
having a hit of marijuana is probably
not going to if I did that it would it
would have no long-term effects on me
and might the benefits might outweigh
the the the risks um and I I have good
friends who have done many many trips on
on five and you know are Psychonauts
they they just really go out there and
they come back and they tell me all
sorts of interesting things and right
now my attitude is um I I hear what
you're saying and you know I don't need
to go there right now myself to do the
work that I'm doing that's trying to put
um structure and and um mathematical
understanding to the kinds of things
that you're you're talking about um but
you know others disagree uh you know my
good friend anah Harris um suggests that
I would be in better shape of and better
able to move forward on on these ideas
if I had firsthand experience um I do I
should say I do meditate quite a bit
I've meditated for 18 years and so I do
let go of all thought I go into silence
and I do explore outside of the geeky
realm in in that way um and but there I
don't feel like I'm very much in danger
of injuring my brain very good so I'm
gonna need to wrap it up um in just a
second or two I want to just reiterate
we're talking to Dr Donald Hoffman who's
at UC Irvine just up the road and uh and
and really an influence um so uh so I
want to just finish up with uh just one
of the questions that I normally ask my
uh my guests who honor Me by their
presence and uh and that is you know
sort of advice to your former self the
name of this podcast the into the
impossible podcast and that comes from
Arthur C Clark who you quote in this
book The very famous line any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable for magic and that is
uh how I open every one of these
podcasts as you'll find out when you
listen to the audio version of it uh his
second law is that for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert and
third law and we all know that in The
Faculty Club I love to love to drop that
little Humdinger on people uh but the uh
the last uh law that derives uh the
derivation of the name of this podcast
is the only way of determining the
limits of the possible is to venture
Beyond them into the impossible I want
to ask you Don advice to your former
self um if you could go back in time and
tell a 20-year old 30-year-old Donald
Hoffman one piece of advice that would
give him the courage to venture into the
impossible as you have done maybe
enabling something new and and at an
earlier phase in in your life what would
that piece of wisdom or advice be well
I'd tell myself a couple things because
I think there's a couple things I needed
to know that I didn't know one is listen
to
authorities but be willing after you've
really studied them to argue against
them
vociferously so don't don't be stupid
and and not listen listen but then have
the confidence to argue against them and
second learn as much mathematics as you
possibly
can right mean that's that is for for
for a theorist translating your abstract
ideas into something that you can really
use and make predictions from is is a
precious gift right now I I have to work
with mathematicians who who are kind
enough to collaborate with me and and
deal with my you know relative lack of
mathematical expertise so I have good
collaborators I would love to I would
have gone back and said you know get a
master's degree at least in mathematics
while you're doing all this other stuff
so you'll have so you can work more on
your own on the mathematical side so so
be brave of course listen to The Experts
but then go and follow your own dream
and your own ideas um but also be humble
about it right you know don't be doe
headed and dogmatic about it that's I
mean that's how you stop inquiry so be
dogmatic about nothing be open about
everything and learn
mathematics very good I think that'll be
the title of the show I want to thank
everybody but especially I want to thank
Dr Donald Hoffman I'm pleased to and
proud to have you as a colleague in the
University of California system please
find his Ted Talk on YouTube it's got
1.57 million views uh and just YouTube
alone find his website find his book the
case against reality which is so
fascinating uh I really found so much in
there that I just could talk to you for
hours what I want to do next is have a
conversation with you and Nema akani
Hamed uh who will uh hopefully we won't
team up too much against the US
physicist but then we'd have on your
side we'll have maybe Dr Stuart Hammer I
don't know we'll convene a big thing if
people on clubhouse think it's cool
let's do it I would thank you Brian I
would love to talk with him I haven't
contacted him because I didn't want to
waste his time I'm reading his stuff he
taught a class at Harvard in Fall of
2019 I have myself personally
translated transcribed 17 of his
lectures I'm learning his stuff that's
how serious I'm about learning his stuff
and because I you know I'm really taken
with his work but I wanted to really
understand his work at a deeper level
before I wasted his time but I would
love to talk with him all right well
I'll get him on my show first and then
we'll get you both together so please
tune in on YouTube Dr Brian keing
subscribe uh to the into the impossible
podcast wherever you get it done have a
wonderful weekend thank you so much for
joining us and going into the impossible